this is uh remember Mason Ramsey what
hits oh this is the dude they would hit
him after his show which is the singer
guy yeah yeah uh but he's got his own
countdown of like when he turns 18 so he
can get all the
the ladies that oh this kid's massive on
YouTube my kids watching
[Music]
oh my God
[Music]
so this kid is what's his name Mason
Ramsey he's massive though remember he
was on Ellen but
um he was the kid in Walmart singing
I know who he is my kids love his [ __ ]
but yeah really just ready to turn 18
and get a bunch of [ __ ]
so hold on so he's
[Music]
is he he's really big huh he's big yeah
still yeah still pretty big
how is the Internet gonna be mad at him
that's what I want to know do you know
what I mean country country doesn't hate
like the rest of the ah yeah he's right
you're right about that good point
good point country like rallies around
each other look at Morgan Whalen yeah
yeah
why not he can sing too yeah
he dresses like Howdy Doody though right
that's a nice shirt come on no that is
no back in the day back in the day he
did but he was he was really his parents
were dressing yeah